about over 100 years ago Mark Twain went
on a trip through Europe he had a debt
to to pay off and so he went on a
lecture tour and wherever he went he
found anti-semitism the result was he
wrote an essay when he came back in 1896
called concerning anti-semitism
concerning the jacket concerning the
Jews and in a way he asked your question
you know why why is it so persistent
what is it that makes it everywhere
because he found he would come to some
people and they would be anti-semitic
because of religion all right then he'd
come to some other place and he found
somebody was an atheist who was an
anti-semite then he finds somebody who
is ignorant
okay so ignorance reset and then he
finds somebody you don't like Voltaire
was an anti-semite so it's and then he
finds somebody who was rich I would say
well you know the Jews are in trying to
be rich and even find somebody poor we
found it that that communist called Jews
capitalist capitalist called Jews
communists whether it was communism or
was fascism or Nazism used the Jew as a
scapegoat and Mark Twain came to a
conclusion I'm not sure it's the proper
conclusion but I haven't found yet a
better one and he says basically that
anti-semitism is a result of jealousy
that there's a jealousy of Jewish
success I I remember about 20 years ago
the anti-defamation they held a
conference we brought together
sociologists educators and public people
to discuss why because there was a
twenty years ago there was an upswing
and I remember somebody around a table
saying well you know what it's because
Jews Excel if so I'll never forget there
was a man there saying you know an
Archie I'll make a deal with you I'll go
home and tell my kids to be number two
or number three if you tell me that
you'll take care of the anti-semitism a
year later so I told the story too
woman who owned some banks in Brazil
called his name was sufferer had been
suffering and he said well to me it's
not a story he said hey you know when we
opened up banco suffre in brazil we were
very successful and I called in my
managers and I said you want to be
successful make sure you're number two
and number three and not number one in
the last yes sorry but I went to Russia
right after glasnost and perestroika and
was invited to address the City Council
of Moscow on anti-semitism so I gave my
presentation and at the end the
gentleman got up and said well mr.
Huntsman but you haven't really told us
why it is anti-semitism
I said well anti-semitism is a disease
really of the Christian world why don't
you tell me so I'll tell you and then he
got up and he said well when I was a kid
in my small town the best students were
Jews and then my became a member of the
Communist Youth party comes from all the
best cups of monix were Jews and then in
university the best students were Jews
and in a communist party the best
comments we chose say says but you know
why there's anti-semitism because
they're only the only excel for
themselves they're only best for
themselves
yes one the first probably in Western
society is the juicer response and
responsible for killing Christ and
that's the mother of all and then I
think the greed issue continues then
then you follow control Jews want to
control the world for their interest it
could be buddy or whatever that's this
conspiratorial Jews are the top of the
hit parade of conspiracy soda for
example we're in an economic crisis in
Europe over 30 percent believe that Jews
are responsible in the United States one
of out of five Americans believes that
Jews are responsible for the economic
crisis because they see Jews and Wall
Street they see Jews everywhere then
then you have different issues of
control of Hollywood is as big and and I
guess it's it's the the whole conspiracy
that and you'll find conspiracies
anywheres so if you don't like something
that's happening maybe you screwed up
you did something wrong it's it's
because the Jews are behind it and you
know there are a lot of people who think
that the Secretary of Treasury is Jewish
is not that Volkers Jewish is not but it
doesn't matter it's the Jews who are
controlling finances it's Jews and
controlling foreign policy there is also
a canard that's out there very big about
loyalty the Jews are not loyal not loyal
to their community but not loyal to
their country thirty percent of the
American people to this day believe Jews
are more loyal to Israel in the United
States in Europe it's 60 70 percent in
Poland sixty percent believe that but
10,000 Jews are not loyal to Poland in
Norway that five thousand Jews at
seventy percent so that's a canard
which goes to the essence that you can't
trust you you can't rely on them and
that as with all the education with all
the exposure you know and and then you
come down to you know some of my best
friends are Jewish you know the guys
that I know they're fine but over
they're out there that's another canard